- Don't be a diva.
- Do I look like a diva?
- [Both] Yes.
Am I gonna act like a diva?
- (upbeat music)
- What do I start with?
I don't know where to start.
- I think maybe like a little foundation,
a little concealer.
- This is like a spirit was hiding in here
and now I just released it.
- Yeah it's supposed to get on your face.
- Tap it a little bit off.
Oh that is so much powder!
- Too much?
- Noooo!
- (laughs)
- This powder's loose AF.
It went straight right to my crotch.
- You got some bags under your eyes.
Do you have any concealer in there?
- We do have concealer.
- Wow this is amazing!
- So there we go.
- I'm gonna actually start using this.
- So yeah for under eye bags
and also like zits and stuff.
- I don't have any of those
cause I'm flawless.
- Ahhh you're perfect!
- This is my favorite thing.
- (laughs)
This is like the Photoshop tool.
- You do want it to have kind of
like a blended look though
so it's not just a patch of brown.
- OK I'm blending, I'm blending.
- Oh I just looked over.
You're definitely using the
wrong brush for that.
Maybe it's a new technique,
I don't know about it.
- It actually works really well.
- We're coming up to a speed bump.
- Ahhh.
- Ok, the only problem right now
is I wanna throw up.
- (laughs)
- [Melissa] Let me see.
- [Both] (laughs)
- Is there too much? Is that a thing?
- You can definitely put too much
green eye shadow on (laughs)
- It looks like somebody
punched me in the face.
- (laughs)
- Right there.
- Oh shoot, I did mess up.
I have this little bit right here.
- Alright and you're blending
and you're putting blue everywhere.
- What's wrong?
- I'm sorry for laughing (laughs)
- You can move onto eyeliner.
- Oh eyeliner. So that's the challenge.
- That's the hardest thing.
- You're going to murder me.
If I lose an eyeball,
- [Melissa] (laughs)
it is your fault
- Ahh it's so scary.
- Yeah smooth road but bad driver.
- Whoa, whoa, whoa because of that,
I'm going through this light.
- Ahhh!
- Damn, this makes you look so hot.
I'm attracted to myself right now.
- Yeah (laughs)
- Oh I wasn't supposed to go all
the way at the bottom, was I?
- No, this is good. This is right.
But I just hate it so much.
- [Jared] (laughs)
- Yeah just brush it on.
- Ow.
- You hit your eye?
- I think so.
- Oh no.
- Oh shit.
- Oh fuck, oh shitholes.
- (laughs)
- How do you not get it on your face?
- You just don't.
- What's left?
- Lipstick.
- So do I use the pointy end
or the flat end?
- Stop moving the car.
- Nooo.
- Stop the car!
- [Melissa] (laughs)
- What's happening?
- [Allison] (laughs)
- Beautiful.
- [Allison] It's not terrible.
- [Steven] Oh wow.
- That's as far as I'll go.
- [Voiceover] Very nice, very nice.
I would say you can maybe just go
with a little bit of a lighter touch
if you're going for an every day look.
- [Geena] I'd have to say like seven.
- [Alex] Seven?
- For a guy.
- For a guy, I get the handicap.
- Or if you were a pre-teen girl.
- Ok so we're all done, Jared.
Um overall, I would say a 10 out of 10.
But I might be biased
because I love you.
- You're the sweetest.
- laughs
(upbeat music)